ya hemos hablado del rotacional donde si
tenemos un campo vectorial b y que tiene
digamos componentes p y q verdad
entonces sabemos cómo calcular el
rotacional en dos dimensiones verdad y
espero que ahora esto sea más que solo
una fórmula para ti y que realmente
comprendas cómo es que esto representa
la rotación de un fluido verdad en dos
dimensiones lo que ahora quiero hacer
aquí es mostrar cómo la intuición
original de la fórmula verdad que hemos
obtenido puede estar sobre simplificada
porque por ejemplo si nos fijamos en
este término de aquí que es la derivada
parcial de q con respecto de x nosotros
dijimos bueno quizás puede ser que
tengamos un punto en donde el rotacional
digamos es cero a su izquierda va para
abajo y digamos que a la derecha va para
arriba entonces estamos pensando que al
movernos en la dirección x al aumentar
en la dirección x cuba pasa del ser
negativo 0 y luego positivo es decir
crece y por lo tanto esta derivada
parcial es positiva verdad y más o menos
nos da la idea de cómo es que está
girando digamos como como en una especie
de remolino pero esta es sólo una
situación muy particular verdad que es
muy específica en donde la derivada
parcial de q con respecto de x es
positiva verdad también podríamos tener
una situación en donde tengamos un campo
vectorial que al aumentar en la
dirección x también aumente la
componente q verdad
digamos que vaya siendo positivo pero
cada vez más positivo esta es otra
situación y para ilustrar lo que esto
significa si nos fijamos en este campo
vectorial en el centro tenemos algo como
en el ejemplo clásico verdad en donde
hay un remolino y que gira en el sentido
contrario de las manecillas del reloj y
si dejamos fluir veremos que en efecto
rota en ese sentido en contraste con lo
que ocurre en esta otra región aquí no
parece que haya rotación sino que las
partículas se apresuran a pasar por ahí
verdad pero de hecho el rotacional
resulta ser igual y eso lo veremos más
adelante
verdad será igual de fuerte que en el
centro pero la imagen que hay que tener
en mente son estas dos paletas verdad y
que si presionamos en medio para que al
dejarlo rotar digamos con el flujo
notaremos que los vectores a la
izquierda empujan un poco hacia arriba
pero no tan fuerte como lo empujan a la
derecha así si imaginamos digamos esta
situación cuando corre el fluido también
rotary a la rueda como en el caso del
remolino y en términos de la fórmula
verdad ambas situaciones nos darían esta
situación que la derivada parcial de q
con respecto de x sea positiva verdad
tanto esta situación como esta otra nos
dan que esta derivada es positiva que es
lo que empezábamos a buscar en el
rotacional en dos dimensiones y por
cierto algo que quizás vale la pena
mencionar en este momento es que el
rotacional es un concepto que que no se
inventó al tratar de entender los flujos
los matemáticos y los físicos en
realidad digamos acuñaron este término y
fue importante
no en ese digamos en términos de flujos
sino en otras circunstancias de hecho
creo que creo que fue más bien en el
electromagnetismo y fue posterior la
digamos la interpretación que dieron en
términos de flujos ahora bien si
regresamos al ejemplo y vemos digamos su
fórmula verdad entonces vamos vamos a
borrar esto de aquí para hacernos
espacio
hagámonos en un espacio entonces
regresemos al ejemplo particular que
hemos dibujado anteriormente ese campo
vectorial que hemos dibujado es muy
simple simplemente la componente p es
menos y la componente q es x muy bien
entonces con esto nosotros podemos
calcular fácilmente el rotacional en dos
dimensiones la derivada de q con
respecto de x es uno y luego restamos la
derivada de p con respecto de ye que es
menos uno entonces uno menos menos uno
simplemente nos da dos y digamos esto es
un número constante en realidad esto nos
dice que no no depende del punto en
donde nos encontremos será exactamente
el mismo rotacional y esto es muy pero
muy muy raro pero lo que nos dice este
número constante es que al fijarnos
digamos en el flujo del rotacional nos
dice que la rotación que ocurre en el
centro es igual de fuerte que digamos la
rotación que ocurre a la derecha o en
cualquier otro lugar si corremos la
animación y pensamos en las paletas
en el centro éstas giran tan rápido
digamos como en el centro como en el
lado derecho y al menos eso a mí me
parece anti intuitivo pero creo que creo
que es importante entender de que otras
formas se puede ver el rotacional en dos
dimensiones y que otras digamos figuras
representa esta fórmula bueno nos vemos